THAT COULD AFFECT ALL  US.
EVERYONE DRIVERS, WE ARE IN A
CAR.
THREE PEOPLE ARE DEAD, 50
INJURED FOLLOWING AN AMTRAK
TRAIN DERAILMENT IN MISSOURI.
THAT TRAIN CARRYING AROUND 243
PASSENGERS.
IT DERAILED WHEN IT HIT A DUMP
TRUCK AT AN UNCONTROLLED
RAILROAD CROSSING.
THEY ARE LAUNCHING A GO TEAM TO
INVESTIGATE.
MARY IS HERE, SHE IS A FORMER
INSPECTOR GENERAL AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION AND
A CNN OFFIATION ANALYST.
MARY, THANK YOU FOR JOINING US.
I WISH IT WAS UNDER BETTER
CIRCUMSTANCES, OF COURSE.
WHAT IS THIS NTSB TEAM GOING TO
BE LOOKING FOR WHEN THEY GET TO
THE SCENE?
>> WELL, THE NTSB TEAM IS GOING
TO BE AIDED, FIRST AND FOREMOST,
BY THE BLACK BOX ON THE TRAIN.
IT HAS FORWARD LOOKING
EQUIPMENT.
THEY WILL BE PULLING THE CAMERA.
IT WILL HAVE THE TRAIN SPEED,
WHEN THE WRIS WHISTLES AND HORN
WAS SOUNDED, THERE ARE
REGULATIONS HOW FAR BEFORE THE
CROSSING THE AUDIBLE SIGNALS
HAVE TO BE SOUNDED.
SPEED OF THE TRAIN.
WHEN THE OPENING NEAR AND TRAIN
CONTROL PERSONNEL APPLIED THE
BRAKES.
THAT GIVES THEM AN IDEA WHEN
THEY SAW THE OBSTRUCTION ON THE
TRACK.
SO BECAUSE OF THAT BLACK BOX
THEY WILL HAVE AN AWFUL LOT OF
INFORMATION TO START WITH.
AND OF COURSE THEY WILL ALSO
GATHER INFORMATION ABOUT THE
TRACK, THE TRACK CONDITIONS,
WHICH RAILROAD OWNS THAT
PARTICULAR SECTION OF TRACK, AND
INFORMATION ABOUT THE SIGNAGE.
APPARENTLY, IT WAS THE STANDARD
CROSS HATCH, CROSS SORT OF SIGN,
NOT ANY LIGHTS OR GATES OR ARMS.
BUT THEY WILL HAVE ALL THAT IN
ADVANCE AND THEN, OF COURSE,
ONCE THEY GET THERE, THE HARD
WORK STARTS OF LOOKING AT THE
TRAIN, THE CONTROLS, MEASURING
EVERYTHING AND ALSO THE
SITUATION OF THE ACTUAL ROADWAY
GOING OVER THE TRACKS.
SO THEY HAVE A LOT TO DO.
>> THIS ACCIDENT OCCURRED AT AN
UNCONTROLLED, AS YOU SAID,
CROSSING MEANING THERE ARE NO
LIGHTS, NO MECHANIZED ARMS.
WHAT ABOUT WHAT -- TELL US
WHAT'S THAT TELL US ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED HERE?
ANYTHING?
>> WELL, IT'S HARD TO JUDGE AT
THIS POINT.
BUT YOU KNOW EVERY YEAR ABOUT
250 PEOPLE ARE KILLED AT
CROSSINGS BECAUSE OF THIS.
THIS IS A FAR FEWER NUMBER THAN,
SAY, 20 YEARS AGO.
20 YEARS AGO IT AVERAGED ABOUT
750 A YEAR.
BUT EVERY YEAR WELL OVER 1,000
ACCIDENTS HAPPEN LIKE THIS WHERE
SOMEONE TRAVELS OVER THE ROAD
AND INTERSECTS WITH THE TRAIN.
IT'S DIFFICULT TO TELL AT THIS
POINT WHETHER THE VEHICLE WAS
STUCK ON THE TRACK, WHETHER IT
WAS A SITUATION WHERE IT
COULDN'T MOVE OUT FAST ENOUGH.
OR DID NOT HEAR OR SEE THE TRAIN
AND SADLY SOME ACCIDENTS ARE
BECAUSE PEOPLE TRY TO BEAT THE
TRAIN.
THE FEDERAL RAIL ADMINISTRATION,
THE DEPARTMENT OF TRANSPORTATION
HAS HAD A GREAT PUBLIC CAMPAIGN
TO EDUCATE PEOPLE NEVER, NEVER
TRY TO DO THAT.
OF COURSE, WE DON'T KNOW IF THAT
HAPPENED HERE.
IT WOULD HELP IF THERE WERE
CAMERAS AT RAILROAD CROSSINGS
LIKE AT INTERSECTIONS IN, YOU
KNOW, CITIES AND ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY LOOKING FOR SPEEDERS.
YOU COULD DO THAT AS WELL.
BUT THERE ARE NOT.
SO THEY WILL HAVE TO JUDGE WHAT
OCCURRED AT THAT CROSSING BASED
ON T